It was one of the greatest states in history.
In the early 20th Century, the Austro-Hungarian
Empire dominated central Europe.
At its height, it stretched all the way from
modern-day Montenegro right up to the Czech-German
border.
Ruled for centuries by a succession of Habsburg
emperors, it seemed as permanent as the United
States does to us today.
Yet, in late 1918, in the blink of an eye,
this great empire collapsed.
The man who kicked its foundations out?
An inexperienced, 31-year old dilettante known
to history as Karl I: the last emperor of
Austria.
Before he dynamited his own empire, Karl had
been an obscure royal from a side-branch of
the Habsburg dynasty.
But a combination of freak tragedies had seen
him propelled to the height of power.
Made emperor before he was 30, Karl inherited
an empire on the losing side of one of the
greatest wars in history.
In his short reign, he first tried to hold
his disintegrating world together… before
finally surrendering to its destruction.
An emperor who killed his empire, a soldier
who may become a saint, this is the fascinating
story of Austria’s last emperor.
A Family in Crisis
Fittingly for a man whose reign revolved around
war, Karl’s story started with a bullet.
Well, specifically, it started with two bullets.
Two shots fired in a palatial hunting lodge
outside Vienna one cold, miserable night in
January, 1889.
Earlier that day, the disturbed young heir
to the Austrian throne - Crown Prince Rudolf
- had requested his 17-year old lover join
him at the lodge.
There, the two had made a suicide pact, before
Rudolf shot her and then turned the gun on
himself.
The death of the heir shook the empire.
It created a scandal that engulfed Vienna,
and emotionally broke the emperor, Franz Josef.
But it did something else, too.
It set Karl on a collision course with destiny.
Born a year and a half earlier, on August
17, 1887, Karl was a young boy from a side-branch
of the Habsburg royal family.
His father, Archduke Otto, was the nephew
of Emperor Franz Josef, and younger brother
of Archduke Franz Ferdinand.
But while both the Franzes were famous for
their pious, Catholic lifestyles, Karl’s
father was infamous for treating life like
one giant frat party.
He drank.
He caroused.
He had affairs that scandalized Austria.
Naturally, this didn’t sit well with his
wife.
Princess Maria Josepha was a strict Catholic
who couldn’t believe her real-life Disney
prince had turned out to be Gaston minus the
muscles.
From the moment Karl was born, she avoided
her husband in favor of their son, taking
him to mass almost every day.
It was a habit that would instill in the young
boy a deep affinity for Catholicism.
So that was the family set-up: a not-so abnormal
tale of parental division that could’ve
gone unchanged for decades… had Rudolf not
fired those fatal shots.
Because Rudolf had been Emperor Franz Josef’s
only son, the line of succession passed to
Karl’s uncle, Franz Ferdinand.
Since Ferdinand was childless, that meant
Karl was now third in line to the throne.
Well, technically.
Franz Ferdinand was only childless because
he was still young.
It was fully expected that he would marry
and start creating mini-Habsburgs that would
knock Karl back out the running to be emperor.
So no-one made any special effort to start
preparing Karl for life at the top.
He was allowed to skip the standard Habsburg
military upbringing, and instead attend a
regular school.
But, events would soon conspire to keep Karl’s
place in the succession.
In 1900, Franz Ferdinand married Sophie Chotek.
Now, Sophie was a Czech countess, but for
a family as absurdly royal and absurdly Austrian
as the Habsburgs, “Czech countess” was
practically synonymous with “trailer trash
tramp”.
Enraged by the match, Franz Josef excluded
Franz Ferdinand’s future children from the
line of succession.
And just like that, it dawned on everyone
that Karl really would be emperor one day.
It was too late to stick Karl on the military
track, so his parents allowed him to go to
university in Prague, to get a regular education.
In the grand, Czech city, Karl absorbed ideas
and attitudes alien to his family; becoming
a cosmopolitan reformist, even as he held
onto his strong Catholicism.
At first, the emperor must’ve consoled himself
that the throne was still a long way from
the boy’s grasp.
But it soon got closer.
On November 1, 1906, Karl’s father Otto
passed away from syphilis, making Karl second
in line, behind only Franz Ferdinand.
Now all it would take would be a single accident
or, say, a single assassin’s bullet, and
19-year old Karl would be the heir presumptive.
No-one knew it in 1906, but that assassin’s
bullet was already in Franz Ferdinand’s
future.
And, when it was finally fired, it was going
to change the entire world.
Prelude to Conflict
For the next eight years, Karl suffered a
crash course in the kind of lives Habsburg
heirs were expected to live.
With the young student now getting worryingly
close to power, Franz Josef abandoned his
previous detachment, and worked flat-out to
whip Karl into shape.
The boy was removed from university, refused
the chance to finish his degree, and dumped
onto an emergency military track that saw
him whisked away to garrisons all over the
empire.
He was also bumped into an arranged marriage
with a bride the emperor thought worthy, the
suitably-wealthy, suitably-royal Zita of Bourbon-Parma.
There’s actually footage of the elderly
Franz Josef at the couple’s wedding, watching
them closely, like a hawk suspicious its prey
might run off at any moment.
He needn’t have worried.
Despite their arranged marriage, Karl and
Zita got along fine, bonding over their shared
Catholic faith and interest in new ideas.
But while Franz Josef may have breathed a
sigh of relief over the wedding, there were
already signs of trouble.
Although Karl was now having a normal Habsburg
upbringing, no-one was actually showing him
how to run an empire.
Franz Josef kept him at arms’ length from
court, possibly on the assumption that Karl
could learn later, when Franz Ferdinand was
emperor.
It was a risky decision.
By the time of Karl’s wedding, Franz Josef
was already in his eighties.
His relationship with his heir, Franz Ferdinand,
was still in the sewer from the whole Sophie
Chotek thing.
If Franz Josef wanted to pass any wisdom on,
now was the time to do it.
But maybe the emperor was simply too busy
come 1911.
After all, his empire was creaking at the
seams.
Although it was known as Austria-Hungary,
the empire Karl would soon inherit was far
bigger than just those two countries.
Alongside Austria and Hungary, it comprised
modern-day Czech Republic, Slovakia, Slovenia,
Croatia, and Bosnia, alongside parts of modern
Montenegro, Italy, Poland, Serbia, Ukraine,
and Romania.
That meant a multicultural empire filled with
different ethnicities, religions, and languages.
It was this multiculturalism that had allowed
Vienna to thrive in the 19th Century.
It was also what was now threatning to pull
it apart.
Nationalism was on the rise across Europe.
Within the empire, the biggest flashpoints
were the succession-minded Czech lands, and
the newly-acquired territory of Bosnia.
The latter was especially volatile.
Only annexed by the empire in 1908, its status
as part of Austria-Hungary was a sore spot
for many Bosnian Serbs, who dreamed of joining
Bosnia and Serbia into a single nation.
But although Franz Josef was aware of the
problems in Bosnia, he seemingly didn’t
realize just how acute they had become until
it was too late.
On July 28, 1914, Karl’s uncle, Franz Ferdinand,
visited Sarajevo as part of his tour of Bosnia.
While he was being driven through the city
in an open-topped car, a young Bosnian Serb
named Gavrilo Princip stepped out the crowd
and fired two shots.
Just as Rudolf’s two fatal shots had many
decades before, these two shots fired in Sarajevo
would change history.
The assassination of Franz Ferdinand meant
Karl became heir presumptive.
Suddenly, from a minor royal, this boy of
not-yet 25 had been propelled to the very
cusp of power.
But no-one apart from Karl was thinking about
this in mid-1914.
The assassination of Franz Ferdinand had already
created much bigger problems.
Convinced the Serbian government had been
behind the murder, Franz Josef declared war.
This led to Russia coming to Serbia’s aid,
which led to Germany coming to Austria-Hungary’s
aid, which led to France coming to Russia’s
aid, and so on and on until the entire continent
was marching to a military drumbeat.
WWI had just begun.
The deadliest conflict the human race had
yet seen would spend the next four years ravaging
Europe.
By the time it ended, in November 1918, Karl
would be emperor of an empire that no longer
existed.
The Soldier
Despite now being heir to the throne, Karl
was still technically a soldier.
So, when the largest war ever seen broke out,
he did what soldiers do.
He went off to fight.
Although the Western Front gets all the English
language press, the Eastern Front was no picnic.
By the time Karl reached Galicia - the little
slice of Ukraine the empire owned - the bloodshed
had already reached staggering heights.
Along the front, the Russian empire was making
mincemeat of the Austro-Hungarians.
In the first two months of fighting alone,
the Russians managed to push 300km into Austrian
territory, capturing Lemberg - now known as
Lviv - and killing over 100,000 Austrian soldiers.
But while the Romanov family was sitting pretty
in St Petersburg, Karl witnessed the slaughter
firsthand.
To say it had an effect on the young man would
be an understatement.
We’ve read sources say he tried praying
on the battlefield to make the bloodshed stop,
but if God was up there, he wasn’t in the
mood for listening.
From September to May, the Russians battered
the Austro-Hungarian army.
As they did so, a few things became painfully
clear to Karl.
The first was that the army was weak not just
because it was in urgent need of modernization,
but because there was something rotten in
Austria-Hungary itself.
The siren song of nationalism was fraying
the empire’s bonds, making its different
ethnicities mistrustful, unwilling to fight
as a team.
The second was that the main threat to the
army might not be marauding Russians, but
getting swallowed by the German war machine.
During the Gorlice–Tarnów Offensive in
mid-1915, Karl saw firsthand how it was only
with German firepower that the empire was
capable of fighting on.
Over the next 18 months, Karl toured the various
fronts of WWI, noting with increasing alarm
the empire’s growing problems.
In northern Italy, he saw how ready to throw
off the Habsburg yoke his subjects were.
On the Eastern Front, he watched as Russian
manpower smashed the Austro-Hungarian armies
until their morale was non-existent.
By late 1916, it was badly clear that - even
if the Central Powers won - the stress of
fighting might kill the empire stone dead.
What was desperately needed was someone new
in charge.
Someone with a vision for how to stop the
slaughter, and pacify the empire’s many
ethnic groups.
Naturally, Karl assumed he should be that
someone.
And he was about to get his chance.
In the early hours of November 21, 1916, emperor
Franz Josef passed away in his bedchamber
in Vienna, after ruling the empire for nearly
68 years.
Immediately, Karl was recalled from the front,
arriving in Vienna shortly after.
There, amid the cold grandeur of the imperial
city, he was proclaimed Karl I: emperor of
Austria.
At the moment he took the title, he was just
29 years old.
From the go, Karl was determined to act on
the lessons he’d learned on the front.
That meant ending the war, and ending it soon.
He even insisted on having the following phrase
inserted into his coronation proclamation:
“I will do everything to banish in the shortest
possible time the horrors and sacrifices of
war, to win back for my peoples the sorely-missed
blessings of peace.”
But despite the new emperor’s grand dreams,
the reality was that peace wasn’t his to
give.
By winter 1916, Austria-Hungary was completely
reliant on Germany.
And the chances of the Kaiser agreeing to
peace were somewhere around the chances of
the Kaiser agreeing to put on heels and dance
for Karl in a Berlin nightclub.
But Karl was not to be deterred.
Even as he was hastily arranging his separate
coronation in the Hungarian half of the empire,
the young emperor was coming up with a dangerous
plan.
The Kaiser wouldn’t let Karl pursue peace?
Then Karl was just gonna have to go over the
old man’s head to get it.
The Emperor
If Karl
wanted his empire to make peace with the Allies,
the first thing he had to do was make sure
it survived long enough.
The disease of nationalism had by now spread
to Vienna itself.
Fearing the divisions if ultra-right Austrians
were given too much control, Karl made one
of his first acts hiring prominent Czechs
into his cabinet.
It was a move meant to neutralize the threat
of Czech secession.
Instead, it just meant Karl became as unpopular
with the Austrians as he was with everyone
else.
And, unpopular was exactly the last thing
Karl wanted to be right now.
That March, 1917, the February Revolution
shook Russia, toppling the Tsar.
And, yes, we agree it’s confusing that a
revolution named after the month of February
took place in March.
Blame Imperial Russia’s weird love affair
with the Julian Calendar.
Anyway, the Wrong Month Revolution put the
fear of God into Karl, who started to worry
that he might be next if he didn’t get this
peace thing sorted.
So he got his wife Zita to contact her brothers,
Sixtus and Xavier, who were fighting on the
Allied side.
He then gave them a secret note to hand to
the French, telling them Austria-Hungary wanted
to make peace.
Today, the Sixtus Affair is infamous for making
Karl look like a jackass.
But, in March and April of 1917, it briefly
looked like the key to ending the war.
When the French received Karl’s overtures,
they laid out a list of cautious demands as
a precondition for talks.
When Karl immediately agreed to most of them,
the French contacted London, being all like
“whoa... this guy’s actually serious!”
Everyone was so excited by the messages that
British Prime Minister Lloyd George remarked
“that means peace.”
But, of course, Lloyd George was wrong.
While Karl was happy to leave Germany hanging,
willing to return land to Serbia, and willing
to recognize French claims to new territory,
he just couldn’t bring himself to give up
the Habsburgs’ last remaining chunks of
Italy.
Since Italy was demanding he do just that
in return for peace, the secret negotiations
eventually fizzled.
With hindsight, Karl’s actions here were
super dumb.
Austro-Hungary’s holdings in Italy were
already small.
While abandoning them would’ve been a bitter
pill to swallow, it could’ve allowed the
empire to survive.
But that was just one of Karl’s contradictions.
He was a wannabee peacemaker, but he was also
a guy who literally thought the Catholic God
had appointed him to rule an indivisible empire.
With that mindset, surrendering territory
was always gonna be a non-starter.
But even though Karl’s negotiations fell
through, it wasn’t the end of the Sixtus
Affair.
On January 8, 1918, Woodrow Wilson set out
his 14 points for peace in Europe, including
self-determination for all peoples of Karl’s
empire - a move that almost guaranteed its
dissolution.
When Karl subsequently tried to strike a more
strident tone against the Allies, the French
published his secret letters.
This is the bit of the Sixtus Affair everyone
remembers, and it was embarrassing as it sounds.
For the Allies, this was final proof that
Austria-Hungary was close to collapse.
For Germany, it was nothing short of betrayal.
That May, the Kaiser angrily summoned Karl.
In a special meeting, he forced the young
emperor to put the Austro-Hungarian military
totally under Berlin’s control.
With the empire now little more than a German
vassal state, the writing was on the wall.
There was no way Karl was escaping this quagmire
without some serious consequences.
But not even the failed emperor could’ve
forseen just how serious those consequences
would be.
Collapse
Across 1918, Karl tried his best to shore
up support inside his ailing empire.
He introduced military reforms.
Banned flogging.
Tried to halt the use of poison gas.
On the domestic front, he set up a welfare
system for returning soldiers, tried to demilitarize
his society.
But it was too little, too late.
When Austria-Hungary entered the war, it was
not a given that it would collapse.
Had Karl’s peace efforts succeeded in 1917,
it seems likely some form of the empire would’ve
survived - minus its Italian, Serbian, and
probably Polish and Czech parts, but still
an empire.
By fall, 1918, though, that ship had long
sailed.
On October 16, Karl published a manifesto
broadly accepting Wilson’s 14 Points, declared
the creation of a federal empire, and granted
every nationality autonomy.
But it was all just theatre.
By now, it was clear WWI was in its endgame.
And it was clear who was on the losing side.
Just 12 days after Karl published his manifesto,
on October 28, the Czechs took control of
Prague and declared their independence.
The very next day, Croatia and Slovenia unilaterally
seceded.
The day after that, Slovakia jumped ship.
That same day, Austria’s politicians declared
the creation of a new, national parliament,
effectively taking Austria out of its own
empire.
Within 24 hours, Hungary’s new leaders had
dissolved the treaty joining their country
with Austria.
On November 11, with only a handful of fragments
of his empire left, Karl gave up trying to
hold on.
He renounced his right to rule Austria, released
his subjects from their oath of loyalty, and
announced he would retreat from politics.
It wasn’t quite an abdication, but it was
very close.
As the guns fell silent along the front at
11am that same day, Austria-Hungary officially
ceased to exist.
It seems Karl still had hope at this point.
Hope his grateful subjects would recall him
for his peace efforts, and ask him to lead
them once again.
It was a nice fantasy, but a fantasy was all
it was.
While some call Karl the “Peace Emperor”
today, the fact is that he totally failed
in his goal of making peace.
WWI had just shattered Europe.
It had claimed over 20 million lives.
No-one but no-one wanted to be led by one
of the guys on its losing side.
Come March, 1919, even Karl seemed to recognize
this.
At the end of that month, he and Zita boarded
a train bound for Switzerland, and set off
for a lonely life as exiles.
In the wake of their departure, the Austrian
national parliament passed a law banning all
Habsburgs from the country, and stripping
them of their right to the throne.
Any sensible person would’ve seen that this
was the end.
That the video was coming to its close, that
the credits on Karl’s life were about to
roll.
But Karl wasn’t sensible.
He was an idealist, and a man who thought
God had handpicked him for greatness.
As he crossed the Swiss border, the deposed
emperor issued his Feldkirch Manifesto, revoking
his own decision to step down, and announcing
he would return to lead Austria-Hungary again.
It was a moment as brazen as it was foolish.
It was also a moment that would soon plunge
the shattered empire right back into chaos.
You Can Never Go Back
Although with hindsight we can see that Karl’s
reign was over, things weren’t so certain
in 1919.
France actually toyed with restoring him and
rebuilding his empire as a counterweight to
Germany.
It was just spitballing, but word somehow
got back to Karl, whose takeaway was that
Paris would support him retaking his throne
by force.
The only problem was, there was no throne
for him to go back to.
Or was there?
In WWI’s aftermath, Hungary very quickly
went through a phase of Communist rule, which
ended with everyone really, super keen to
do the opposite of Communism.
In February, 1920, Miklós Horthy came to
power, restored the monarchy, and named himself
regent in Karl’s name.
For Karl, this was a clear signal that the
Hungarians, at least, wanted him back; and
he wasn’t totally mistaken.
But there was one Hungarian determined to
make sure Karl never retook his throne.
Horthy may have restored the monarchy, but
only as a means to power.
After all, what’s a regent when his king
is capable of ruling?
A nobody.
So when Karl snuck into Hungary in disguise
on March 26, 1921, Horthy did everything in
his power to keep the young man from unseating
him.
When they met, he told Karl that of course
he supported him, that of course he’d help
him march on Budapest.
Then, when the emperor was good and mollified,
Horthy snuck off and asked the French if they
were, like, actually serious about supporting
Karl.
To Horthy’s delight, the French were not
serious about it at all.
Paris announced they’d had no part of this,
that Karl was both an idiot and on his own.
This delighted Prague, and the Czechoslovaks
immediately threatened to declare war on Hungary
if it restored the emperor.
And that’s how Karl wound up fleeing into
exile in Switzerland for the second time.
But the last emperor wasn’t done trying
yet.
That fall, Karl contacted Hungary’s elites,
making sure to exclude Horthy.
He managed to drum up an army of 5,000 loyalists.
On October 20, the emperor flew a flight plane
to the border town of Sopron, where his army
was waiting for him.
Initially the venture had all the hallmarks
of a glorious homecoming.
The people of Sopron celebrated Karl’s return.
As his army began the long march to Budapest,
more and more joined their ranks.
For one shining moment, it really looked like
Karl was going to get his empire back.
And then the army reached Budapest and everything
fell apart.
No-one seems quite sure what happened that
strange day.
We’ve seen sources claim Horthy tricked
the citizens into taking up arms against Karl,
believing he was at the head of a Czechoslovak
invasion force.
We’ve seen others say Karl was betrayed
by one of his generals.
The only thing certain is that Karl entered
Budapest on October 23.
By October 24, he’d been captured, and his
last chance at restoration was over.
This time, it wouldn’t end with comfy exile
in Switzerland.
On November 1, the irate British sailed a
warship up the Danube, and demanded Karl be
handed over.
They then took him away - away from Hungary,
away from mainland Europe - away to the Portuguese
island of Madeira, some 900km from the mainland.
And they left him there.
And that was it for Austria’s last emperor.
On April 1, 1922, Karl succumbed to pneumonia
- some sources say Spanish flu - and passed
away, aged just 34.
At the time he died, his name was mud across
Europe.
His former nations had all passed laws banning
him from their territory.
He was seen as a weakling at best, a laughingstock
at worst.
But things soon started to change.
In the aftermath of WWII, with its overtly
evil trio of Hitler, Mussolini, and Stalin,
a bumbling Habsburg who’d sincerely tried
to make peace suddenly didn’t look so bad.
As WWI began to be viewed as a gigantic, needless,
morally gray screw-up, Karl’s determination
to end the war eventually began to appear
decent.
Even noble.
In 2004, over 80 years after Austria’s last
emperor died in misery, Pope John Paul II
beatified him for his peacemaking efforts.
As of the time of writing, Karl is on the
path to sainthood.
Is it the fate he deserves?
Who can say.
While Karl really did try to make peace, he
also really was an ineffectual bumbler, who
failed to end the war his empire was part
of.
They say that all it takes for evil to triumph
is for good men to do nothing.
What they neglect to mention is that - sometimes
- good men really can try to do something,
and still fail to stop the slaughter.
Karl may have been a decent man deep down.
But if his story shows us anything, it’s
that decency isn’t always enough.
Sometimes, you can do everything in your power
to hold your country together, and still wind
up being known to history as
the last emperor.